this is tomorrow reading for reviewer
mark delaney horror fans are living in a
golden age it seems like a few major
horror franchises are adapted into games
every year most often in the
asymmetrical multiplayer genre casting a
group of friends as hapless survivors
against another player hunting them as a
supernatural foe is a great idea on
paper every time even as end results can
dramatically vary evil dead the game
doesn't stray far from this foundational
premise however it smartly leans on its
b-movie hijinks to deliver fans
something worthy of being in their
horror game rotation even if it doesn't
have the soul to swallow all their time
single-handedly
while evil dead the game is its official
title you could rightly call it
fanservice the game instead drawing from
the original three movies and the star
series sorry reboot fans evil dead beams
with pride and fandom from its
developers collecting all manner of
weapons easter eggs locations and corny
one-liners that made the series famous
when evil shows up it blows her
original actors are brought back in most
cases including the all-important bruce
campbell whose many versions of ash
williams make up a good portion of the
character's roster wandering across the
game several large maps can feel like a
museum tour through one of horrors cult
favorite franchises the audio and
visuals lend themselves to this glowing
first impression too music straight from
the series and faithful character models
including the nauseatingly detailed dead
eyes make evil dead the game feel as
lovingly crafted as the movies i do wish
the characters had more voice lines
however there are only so many times i
can hear ash make the same joke about
his flashlight before the b-movie hero
loses his lustre let's do this with the
lights on
thankfully much of the game's other
overt fan service sets an enjoyable
scene to play within
stepping into the nobi cabin fills me
with the same sort of wonder a child
might feel when they first cross the
threshold into disneyland while the
woods of evil dead are not just below
iconic settings like elm street or camp
crystal lake the swirling winds give
each map a recognizable feeling of
uneasiness and oppression even as it's
all mixed up with the campy series's odd
hatchet wielding monsters wearing
varsity jackets the set dressing makes
evil dead a game loyal to its source
material but in trying to be so faithful
sometimes the gameplay suffers the
game's central mode is survivors versus
demons and while the four survivors are
played by humans the monster opposing
them can be battled in pve or
asymmetrical pvp cleverly the demon
player does not control just one deadeye
but acts more like the director of each
round's chaos as the demon you can float
around the map unseen to survivors set
traps spawn enemies or briefly possess
the bodies of deadites or even survivors
if you scare them enough playing as the
monster is unpredictable because you're
first tasked with hunting down the
survivors then ruining their chances of
winning but as the survivors the
objectives are much more routine and as
a result they can become boring because
the movies focus so much on the book of
the dead and a very specific ritual for
exercising the dead eye
the multiplayer objectives don't ever
stray from that cannon path in a game
like friday the 13th part of the
excitement is the number of ways
survivors can win calling the cops
killing jason escaping in a vehicle and
so on when evil dead the same exact
steps must be taken to win in every
single round find three map fragments
survive two short horde waves then kill
the dark ones which tends to feel too
easy before protecting the necronomicon
while a final two minute countdown
unfolds
it's formulaic in service to its source
sure the location of key items like map
fragments will vary from round to round
but it starts to feel bro after just a
few hours
one refreshing change evoda does bring
to the genre is survivors who can fend
for themselves in similar games the
survivor's choices essentially boil down
to running or dying but those seeking
the necronomicon can equip weapons found
as tiered loo upgrade their abilities
both during and between rounds and when
working closely together leave the demon
player or ai with very little room for
error the class-based heroes each have
special abilities that promote organized
teamwork like a healing ability for
support characters and a calming effect
that the game's leaders can apply so the
rest of the group keep their cool in the
face of danger without this character's
fear meter can rise leaving them
vulnerable to possession survivors can
slash and bash heads off of monsters and
apply amulets like body armor standing
toe to toe with hordes of dead eyes at a
time
the melee animations can be a bit janky
as finishers will lock you into kill
animations while your allies may still
be slashing and shooting at the same
enemy for a moment thereafter but an
easy to learn dodge mechanic and rather
small health bars give combat some much
needed tension and even run-of-the-mill
enemy encounters it looks messy in
practice but it's as reliable as it
needs to be out of the gate the game
actually feels slightly unbalanced in
favor of the survivors as the demon's
ability cooldowns can be lengthy and
unforgiving in a round where both teams
are playing at a high level it feels
like early objectives are weighted
towards the demon while the latter
objectives favor survivors which means
any demon player who struggles to find
the group fast is likely boxing
themselves out of a win it's fun to be
able to possess the survivors as the
demon taking unabated control of their
bodies for a short while which lets you
hack away at their friends or run them
away from objectives and towards other
danger in isolation but a group of
survivors playing like a well old
machine is basically insurmountable even
for an adept demon player like a lot of
games of this nature evil dead is best
played with a group of friends and the
experience often degrades when played
with strangers online worst of all those
who want to play the game totally alone
will find evil dead to be hostile
towards their preference playing in solo
pve lobbies awards you with no
experience points so you can't unlock
new character abilities and the game's
short run of campaign missions doesn't
add more to the experience each mission
is inspired by scenarios from the series
like ash needing to bury his girlfriend
linda's severed head while demons
inhabiting her oscillate between mocking
him and pleading for his mercy that's a
fun nod to the first two movies but it's
also hard to see each of the game's five
missions as anything other than a 20
minute detour away from the game's true
mode which actually doles out xp and has
progression the series is focused on ash
williams means about a third of the
class-based roster is just different
versions of the protagonist from the
last 40 years it's neat to see different
versions of ash are given different
classes such as hunter support or leader
to reflect his character growth over the
years but when i load into a game and
the entire team is a different version
of bruce campbell it's a reminder that
the franchise doesn't actually have many
characters and it isn't as suited to a
game like this as other series at least
no matter who you play as the xp system
is welcoming there's both character xp
and account xp and you can spend the
latter on any character you'd like this
is very helpful as it means even if your
preferred survivor is claimed by another
player for a round you can finish out
the match and commit your account xp to
your favorite character alternatively
you could min max one hero or villain at
a time and double down by moving all xp
gains to a single character the xp
rewards are slow and require a lot of
time to max out even just one character
but like the aforementioned demon
cooldowns this is an issue that could
presumably be solved with a basic patch
it's not game breaking by any means but
in its current state it definitely needs
some work evil dead the game is faithful
but sometimes to a fault if there were
more game modes or even more varied
objective in its one attractive game
mode it would feel more like a game for
horror fans to play for a long time
maybe even moving competitors like dead
by daylight or hunt shell down off their
wanted pedestals as it stands at launch
however evil dead only reaches beyond
something pretty good when it's played
with a close-knit group of evil dead
fans general horror and co-op
enthusiasts may get some mileage out of
it but ash and his boomstick are
storming into a crowded field of
competitors and can't quite overcome the
horde of similar games already available
[Music]